well thank you for coming this morning
we are trying something a little bit
different this startup school year we
are not just having our weekly to
lectures but we are having some
conversations with notable people and I
couldn't be happier to have one of the
most notable startup people here he'll
get embarrassed when I say anything
complimentary so I'll try to avoid it
Paul Graham my friend and the the
founder of Y Combinator back in 2005 and
we're just going to talk and hopefully
it won't be boring Paul yes Jeff so you
and I got to know each other
strangely at a it was kind of a start-up
at the time Yahoo back in the late 90s
98 yeah guys know he wrote Yahoo Mail
some of it yeah
Y Combinator has the people who wrote
Yahoo Mail and Gmail that is weird right
Paul Buchheit who who actually has more
of a claim on actually writing Gmail
than I do have a claim on writing Yahoo
I wrote I wrote some important parts of
Yahoo Mail but Paul was kind of by
himself doing G almost and we had we
were a little more intentional with
yahoo mail and had had a team creating
something called rocket mail but it is a
little weird that both of us ended up at
YC years later uh but Paul was at Yahoo
I was at Yahoo because we created
something called rocket mail and we were
purchased in 97 but a Paul's company was
bought in 98 and so how can you you had
this weird idea for a product for
something you thought people would would
want in in the mid-90s which had to do
with like SAS before SAS was a thing how
did you come up with this idea for for
via web the company that Yahoo bought
okay so
what we made was something that is now
called a web app I believe at the time I
was the first one and that's why the
company was called via web because it
worked
via the web and the way I remember very
vividly we thought back then everybody
thought that writing software was
identical with writing software that ran
on the client and we're still for those
of you who remember the mid-90s the
client meant Windows right and like we
knew how to write software for UNIX and
we liked UNIX we did not know how to
write software for our windows but we
knew enough to know that we did not want
to learn and so we were really really
highly motivated to figure out how to
write software without having to write
software to run on Windows and so we
thought to ourselves well maybe well you
know the way I first thought of it
actually was that you would have this
you would have it was an online store
builder right and I thought that you
could you could send it updates by email
that was I thought you can send it
updates by email right um and it would
change your website and then I remember
thinking well if you Coster us for
shopping carts or whatever if you can
use SMTP why not HTTP to update your
website whoa you could cut the software
could run on the server and you could
control it by clicking on links in the
browser would that even work right but I
remember I was like sleeping on a
mattress on the floor in Roberts spare
bedroom and I remember I sat up in bed
when I thought of this like like the
letter L right it was actually like one
of those scenes in a movie I'm like oh
my god we could avoid having to write
software on Windows at all
we never at that point we were never
thinking about the benefits of web apps
which are great as it turned out we were
just thinking we could like actually do
this without ever having to learn
pointing windows you did yeah at ER that
like you could deploy then without
having to ship software did none of that
avoiding windows we could actually write
thank-you gates never have to learn
windows because like the Netscape people
had already gone through the pain of
making Netscape work on Windows
hey just like that was like a hole onto
Windows you know and people could get
through the hole and click on links in
the browser and control the software and
so we immediately we weren't even sure
this would work because it was so weird
but we immediately sat down and tried to
write this really really clunky website
builder that worked by clicking on links
it was terrible but it did actually work
it could make a website and I'm like
holy [ __ ] this actually works that's
weird that like an innovative idea like
that just sort of comes out of no I mean
it scene doesn't seem innovative now
because all websites work that way but
the first one like that's that's going
from 0 to 1 how do you like it's very
common happen right very common for
ideas in retrospect they see him obvious
and you and Matt you sort of historians
who weren't there
sort of straighten out all the kinks in
the development and it just seems like
oh they had this you know it's like this
idea I always hate it when people
represent startup ideas as light bulbs
you know because as well as being the
most cliched metaphor imaginable it's
also false you don't just like have this
idea and then realize it right no it's
more like you have this sort of inkling
that something you could do something
that somebody else hasn't done before
and it's probably a bad idea
but you're too lazy to learn Windows and
so you want to do it that way right um
and so or like who would or like Zuck
starting Facebook you know just like
let's see what happens right the way
implausible if this would ever be a
startup which is good for you all
hopefully some of your ideas seem really
implausible right I love it when ideas
seem implausible in the right way over
the years I mean I already had just from
being a hacker as sort of a good nose
for this sort of thing but it has become
refined over all these years of dealing
with startups and when when people have
I was talking to some people yesterday
and they were talking about two possible
things they could
and one of them seemed so it seemed like
naughty not like it was it was it was
sort of maltreating anyone it was just
sort of taking advantage of something
that seems like it shouldn't even be
possible right like like making this
software run on the server and just like
never making software that seemed to the
users to run on their computer but
actually was just talking to them
through the browser that kind of
naughtiness and then I said like pick
that one because it seems it seems so
outrageous it seems so hilarious it
seems like there's all these ways we
have talking about what's a good idea
and when you try to match up ideas with
them it's always sort of a complicated
you know it's like is this idea naughty
or is it is it is it is it like not
quite intuitive or not so javea and it's
really always hard to to take any
particular idea and say is that the one
was potential well you can't tell in
fact that's another thing um it's not
just that the outcomes of startups are
hard to predict I think to some degree
they're actually indeterminate there's a
huge amount of luck involved you know
and so I think even if even if Y
Combinator were as good at picking
startup so you could possibly get I mean
in fact you have like 150 startups per
batch of which maybe 5 will become giant
or something like that
hopefully high that would be good yeah
well depends on your definition of giant
right it's a power-law distribution
we're like if for some definitions of
giant one of it one is taking any
batches will think if five or any
definition of giant yeah we'll be happy
so talking about I like oh yeah the
indeterminacy of yes even if you were
able to pick perfectly that doesn't mean
you could get the batches down to only
five startups you probably have to pick
twenty I think even if you were perfect
so it just it's just it's hot it's hard
like it's hard to know there's this
there's a strange mix of extraordinary
hard work an idea that actually has
something to it but is not obvious it's
hard for founders to know yeah you don't
know yourselves
you don't know yourselves I mean I mean
you don't know comma yourselves not that
you don't know yourself so that it's
also true so and that's why it's good to
be a hacker because if you're some
business person you know and you think I
am going to work on business
opportunities right well I don't know if
this is a business opportunity so I'm
not gonna work on it um whereas someone
who's a hacker who's just doing things
for the fun of it or because they don't
like Windows yeah laziness to this is
actually in some cases really helpful at
least some kinds of some kinds of later
I'm a little scared about this meme
escaping into the wild right
can't you just see well yeah you just
see it's it's truly they said laziness
is good he said from the sofa as he ate
another doughnut you know it would be
better if people thought laziness wasn't
good because the glaze enos the kind of
the people to you that's good they do
and they would do anyway even if they
thought it's weird yeah well using
laziness not in the normal sense of
laziness right because if you're late
there's there's no such thing as a lazy
founder that it builds a big company
there's but but a certain sort of it's
sort of a reticence to do something for
some reason I'm calling it lazy
weightings not really it seemed like
sort of slaps it makes you it you know
if you have a natural hatred for
gratuitous slap slaps like then what
that that produces elegant solutions so
so in 1995 ish I was like trying every
single idea I could possibly try to
start some internet business and I was
doing it all by myself which was awful
and and what I didn't know how to do was
to find people to do it with and I kind
of ran into a bunch of people and I had
no clue whether they would be good
people to start companies with and I was
thinking about your experience you said
you were like sleeping on Roberts well
you started you started via web with two
fascinating people Robert Maxwell and
trevor Blackwell who later robert morris
robert morrison and trevor blackwell
robert maxwell
Morrison Trevor Blackwell and that's a
that was a weird mix of names anyway um
how did you pick them as co-founders how
did that happen and and when did you
decide they would be good co-founders
were they good co-founders um alright so
yeah right
they're extremely worked they were
extremely truculent co-founders who were
very good at programming but I remember
Robert was like not into the whole
startup thing the entire way like
whenever he was on the board and
whenever we got and whenever you get an
acquisition offer the board has to at
least consider it right and so we would
get these crap lowball acquisition
offers we'll give you like two million
dollars in our stock right was like yes
no no Robert would say like we would
vote on it and Robert would always say
well you know I have to be honest here
like this would at least mean we could
stop working on this thing and so yes I
would take this deal right I made a deal
with Robert that if he ever made a
million dollars out of out of via Web he
would get an earring Robert it's not the
kind of guy who would enjoy having an
earring let me tell you um and so as
soon as the deal closed me and Trevor
frog-marched him to the place in Harvard
Square where people get their things
pierced never heard this before he got
him an earring there's photographs on
the internet if Robert Morris with an
earring that he didn't keep it when his
but not for long we should have
specified that I never thought I never
thought to specify you know I thought
you'd actually get the million dollars
no no I really actually did but I
thought he would wear it for a bit
longer
um when his fiancee saw it she fell on
the floor why did you choose why did I
try killing Trayvon ders okay so I chose
Robert because he was my co-conspirator
in everything and I don't mean I was
always I was always the lead and he was
just the co-conspirator when he did
things I would be his co-conspirator to
you so like the internet worm if 19 you
guys know Robert Morris's is pretty
famous all on his own
yeah he invented buffer overflow and I
remember when he told me about it and I
said wow what a cool idea she totally
do that he was the first famous hacker
who really got in trouble I think yeah
really in trouble he was the way it's
true he was the first person to be
prosecuted under the Computer Fraud and
Abuse Act of 1986 which so if you're
looking for a co-founder look at people
who have been prosecuted because it
works
yeah user he is actually a convicted
felon okay this is another mean we don't
necessarily want to escape out there
that convicted felons are what you want
to look for as co-founders they're
convicted for that maybe it was funny
because the FBI like like law
enforcement kind of does things by the
book right like imagination is a big
thing in in like Sherlock Holmes stories
but not in actual everyday law
enforcement and so they have these the
FBI agent told me like they have these
motive they look for sex drugs money
revenge right
and so like Robert did it out of
curiosity and that's just think it's
just not on the list hey they really had
a hard time figuring out what the hell
was going on I think even within the
government there were lots of people who
did never understood what was going on
so back to Robert and Trevor whoo-hoo oh
so why did I pick Robert Trevor yeah
Robert Robert Robert I picked because I
would I would do everything with him
right we had all these schemes and so
you knew you could work with him I mean
I could work with him when I knew it was
really good he was a really good
programmer he could program as fast as
he could type of course this was in C
which is a lot of very verbose language
but but he could program as fast as he
could type he was amazing he would like
if he didn't like what the operating
system would do it he would edit the
source and recompile it and then it
would do what he wanted
so truculence aside he was exceptional
like when he showed up at Harvard
undergrads were only allowed to have
accounts on like the official undergrad
computing system off in the Science
Center and there were all these real
computers in the cs department and let
aiken lab and so they wouldn't give him
an account there and so he just walked
up to you a machine
you know switched it to single user with
him as the super user gave
cellphone account and then and switched
it back hey it was curious yeah well he
also wanted to counts on the right
machines he got kicked this whole thing
will be about Robert Robert such an
interesting character I shouldn't talk
about it may be more interesting than
anything else we can talk about he got
kicked out of Harvard as an undergrad
for reconnecting Harvard to the Internet
um Harvard Harvard had been one of the
early internet nodes that's so funny to
like like get interval for disconnecting
a school from the internet connecting it
can happen for connecting a school where
were we
well we're still trying to figure out
why the heck uh
oh I should tell you though about how we
tell us about the disconnecting really
fast no no it's okay so we have all day
we don't do it no we don't okay how long
have we have we have enough time we have
the same watch more or less Robert okay
it was one of the very early internet
nodes and by the time Robert arrived in
as an undergrad the connection had died
from bit decay that's like no one
noticed that's how unimportant the
internet was back then or rather ARPANET
as it was then called verily an Internet
right so RT M spent one whole semester
working on getting Harvard reconnected
RT M is Roberts yes yes Robert and he
like didn't do any work for any of his
classes and he got such bad grades he
got kicked out for a year so we actually
used that later as a recruiting
technique because we knew there because
there might be other people who got
kicked out for spending all their time
on some project and so we actually went
around Harvard and posted up this poster
saying did you get kicked out working on
some project of your own we'd like to
hire you I think there's probably so we
got a really grid programmer that way
um there's probably something made tons
of money off of options cuz we got
acquired journey here right and you like
enjoyed life out of school so much I
don't think he went back until he was 25
so um all right so why did why Trevor
why Trevor well so you picked Robert
Robert was what was the guy you did
everything with and he was great okay so
after we'd been doing before the wave
when you picked Robert did you know he
was gonna be a pain in the ass in so
many ways as you like or was that a
surprise to you well I knew he was a
pain in the ass I didn't know the
company was gonna be so hard and it
would bring out so much penis so you
didn't realize how hard tell you the way
we got Trevor was very indicative yeah
so a month in we'd been working on this
company for a month and Robert rebels he
says we've been working on this company
for a whole month and it's still not
done and I thought hmm maybe we need
more programmers so so I said all right
Robert who's the smartest person you
know in grad school and he said Trevor
right and I said Trevor right and
Trevor's one of those people who seems
of a lot smarter than you seems so but
it's Trevor is actually super smart and
so we went and recruited Trevor and he
said oh okay that's that's a really good
Trevor but almost not a Canadian Trevor
has two modes oh okay and oh I'm sorry
which is what he does when he does
something that breaks everything which
was very common very common and so we
got Trevor I recruited Trevor to work on
the thing he does nothing for two weeks
at least as far as I can tell he just
disappears and then two weeks later he
says come into my office and he's
rewritten all our goddamn software in
small talk typical yes um so I said all
right Trevor we're not using that but do
this instead right
um and so Trevor like Trevor was like
this super productive hacking monster
but you didn't know that in advance you
just trusted Robert when Robert told you
he was really smart well if Robert said
he was the smartest he's deaf
the smartest but there's kind of a deep
lesson in that and how you how you pick
whether whether it's employees or
co-founders it's you find someone you
trust and then find someone they trust
yeah although here's an interesting
point that works better for some
qualities than others like intelligence
the intelligent people can judge other
intelligent people but trustworthy
people cannot judge other trustworthy
people in fact trustworthy people are
often fooled by untrustworthy people so
like Kate quarto is like our architect
who did this is like super trustworthy
but she's always fooled by easily sneaky
schemers you know who take advantage of
her so I guess that means you take
recommendations from people but then you
have to add your own no no no you can
totally dress but if Robert says
someone's smart and I disagree I think I
must be wrong right yeah but you need to
just works for some qualities better
than others let's hold right you want
them to be trustworthy when they join
you as a co-founder so you have to add
that for the trustworthiness yes this
whole thing of like networking doesn't
work it doesn't you have to have someone
you can judge whether people are
trustworthy which I'm I am not even good
at I am not good at the person who does
that for Y Combinator is Jessica the
social radar the secret power behind
everything so you did hire people at via
web - yes what did you learn about
hiring in your like your first startup
like so you learned that they they if
they were getting lousy grades your
start working on a project that seemed
good which is which is kind of
counterintuitive a lot of things we seem
to do it.why see end up being
counterintuitive startups in general are
very very counterintuitive and so that's
actually why C exists if it was obvious
what to do and starting a start-up we
wouldn't why C couldn't really add much
by teaching people how to do it right
and so I often say I often in fact
practically every day if I do office
hours I'm reminded of this that like
what Y Combinator does is tell founders
things that they ignore right so we tell
people don't hire to you fast and then
they go off and hire to you fast and
then they come back later and say oh I
wish we'd listened but
all the things we tell people we tell
people the counterintuitive stuff not
the obvious stuff and then what
counterintuitive means is it sounds
wrong and so they go with their gut and
do the wrong thing instead and then
hopefully catch the mistake in time why
is it that startups are so
counterintuitive you know that would be
if that would be very much writing an
essay about that would be worth writing
an essay about why startups are so
counterintuitive I don't know I don't
know I don't know it's I could come up
with some theories but I have a feeling
the answer is so interestingly
complicated that would be unlikely to
come and it's really just we were just
talking about one of the things that
that you you did write an essay about
which is somewhat counterintuitive when
you start a startup and you're like okay
now I'm gonna grow and then you write a
whole bunch of stuff but you've already
software that helps you grow and and
you're at a whole si says don't do that
do things that don't scale in the
beginning yeah do things that don't
scale because growth is maybe you can
start by saying what it means to do
things that don't scale because I'm
afraid the best thing you did not
already I'm sure you've all read all as
well as I say but this is a this is
actually very important because most of
you all have early startups and when you
do an early startup it's become our
mantra YC and I've seen it again and
again you should not try to do too much
in the beginning you should do things
that don't scale what doing things that
don't scale means specifically is doing
things in a sort of handmade artisanal
painstaking way that you feel like yeah
it would be great if you could do things
that way forever but you and you're in
the back of your mind you think to
yourself well there's no way we can keep
doing this and become giant right and
what do things that don't scale means is
do those things early on anyway because
you know if you don't do them you'll
never be big and you've got nothing to
lose and also you learn a lot from it
you learn a lot and so I discovered a
lot of this things that we teach
startups at Y Combinator or you teach
startups the Y Combinator I'm retired I
don't know if you know that
but a lot of things you guys teach
startups is are things that I hit myself
and didn't realize that they were
actually common startup lessons so one
of them is doing things very manually
for your early customers like it's so
important to get early customers that if
you have to do a ton of manual stuff
that's ok you'll learn a lot from it did
you guys do manual stuff oh yeah well
totally and we thought oh we're doing it
wrong this is so lame and in fact it was
exactly the right thing
we made an online store builder you
could build a store on the internet and
sell stuff and we would go to would be
would be customers and say would you
like to use our easy online store
builder and they would say no and we
would say but you want an online store
right and they would say yeah and and
they would say well what if we use we
would say what if we used our software
for you to make an online store and then
you could have it would that be good and
they'd say all right and so we'd like we
can't get anyone to use our software but
at least they're willing to let us use
it for them and it seemed it seemed so
lame I learned so much [ __ ] about like
direct marketing as it turns out it's
called we were members of the DMA the
Direct Marketing Association that's what
you know in every business card carrying
member the DMA were we were in every
business they have a name for the
business that's not the name Outsiders
call it like fast food no no no they
don't call it that they call it fast
casual within the industry right and in
in the catalog business that used to
call the direct marketing industry right
um so that's what the dma meant back in
those days the catalog business we
signed up for every catalog you know his
catalogs you get in the mail we would
just like write a wide right and ask for
more well you had this like bookshelf
full of every catalog ever yeah it seems
like almost like if you were building a
new search engine and what you ought to
do is have a have your box out there and
then just take all the searches manually
and like get results and throw them out
there and see what see what happens I'm
trying to think what we did for mail
that was manual in the beginning we we
sort of a manual ad server like we
didn't really have ad serving technology
we just throw at like I wrote it so it
wasn't really good and and we would just
throw them in there that there's a deep
lesson there for four for four people
though like what happens if you think
you know the solution and you build lots
of stuff for it you're going to be wrong
because you just don't know and having
to use our software myself made it much
better because I would be using our
software to make someone's website right
and I was also the guy who wrote the
site builder and so I would be using and
think to myself this is inconvenient
it's like going in the middle of
building their site I would change the
software and I mean ship as in like MV
and like that's like that's the great
thing about server based software ship
is the UNIX MV command so well know CP I
would want to keep a copy but but I
would like change the software in the
middle of using it and then go back to
working on their website and boy did
that make that that made the software
much better that I had to use it yeah so
um so picking co-founders you want to
pick the best people who you can somehow
believe are trustworthy
it's probably helpful for a lot of
people I think a lot of people taking
the class or sole founders now yeah why
is it that that sole founders that being
a sole founder is so difficult Wow um
there's so many different reasons like I
think the hardest part is more L there's
no one there's like if you have multiple
people they keep one another going when
things are going badly and there's no
one to cheer you up
that's what's hard for me I remember 95
I'd be like I know this internet thing
is gonna be real but damn oh so you were
sole founder yeah yeah
that's why his hair is greater than mine
the yeah like being a sole founders hard
like it's hard because there's a million
reasons why what you're doing isn't
going to work and mostly you're right so
it's easy to convince yourself to used
used to say this and I always remember
to used to say look you have two choices
as a founder do you remember what you
would say after that well there's so
many different cases this versions of
this what will he would say you could
either quit or get rich mmm yeah die or
get rich like the company's a lot of
versions well that's what happens with
startups mostly the company either dies
or it's something succeed you get rich
and you know getting rich can mean you
know you have a nice little business
where you're the boss and you have 20 or
50 employees or it could mean your
Airbnb right they're both good outcomes
not as good for your investors
necessarily but for you it really good
and and doing things that don't scale
that's hot you know and internalizing
what that really means I was thinking
about you know one of the it's the sort
of things that don't scale we talked
about at YC all the time we say you're
supposed to for success you talk to
users and write code you you talked and
if you think about it talking to users
especially as sort of the founder
doesn't really scale very well but
that's what it forces you to do if you
have to do everything it doesn't scale
it forces you to learn right in the
beginning you only have ten customers
you want to grow to 20% you want to go
10% next week 10% weeks an ambitious
goal you only got to get one more
customer you can go out and do that very
manually right and then next week you
have eleven customers you have to get
1.1 customers right so this is basically
one right you just keep going out there
and doing things manually and as long as
your growth rate is good it doesn't
matter how small the number is because a
grow a constant growth rate means
exponential growth and that means the
base number will soon take care of
itself
it's kind of thinking about what makes
companies good what makes companies fail
and I was thinking about maybe how we
could talk a little bit about some of
those those aspects of
of how people can kind of figure out how
they're doing here we have thousands of
companies out in start-up school and
trying to figure out what to do next and
whether they're doing the right thing
and whether they're failing and whether
they're on the right path
what makes companies fail most of the
time is poor execution by the founders
right um we we often talk to startups
who are worried about competitors and
one good event one advantage of why is
he having funded so many companies you
have a really large data set and like
how many companies have been killed by
competitors one more than one out of
nineteen hundred right um so I tell
startups that basically you have the
same protection against competitors
that's that light aircraft have against
crashing into other light aircraft when
flying through clouds
you know what the protection is space is
large hey this little Cessnas don't have
any radar in them you know you can't see
in clouds it's this it's it this falls
under the rubric of counterintuitive
advice because one of the things that
happens all the time is people come up
and say oh my god there's another new
company what should I you know that's in
exactly my space what should I do
right and it's sort of like if you're
running the hundred meters right and
suddenly there appears another lane with
another runner in it what should you do
you run as fast as you can just like you
presumably were or hate if they're
better than you they'll win and if not
then then you'll win and that's a good
reminder could everyone please silence
your phones if you haven't already yeah
what else like like one of the one of
the things we do a lot is try to judge
Wright companies in it founders Nick
who's gonna succeed and and and you guys
are doing the same thing except you're
trying to pick yourselves hopefully what
what what is it that
then make startup succeed that makes
startup succeed well you have to start
with a good founding team ideally not
just one person that's my quote you can
do it with one person well I couldn't I
couldn't III I ended up I ended up
having to join other people like I
actually think oh that's majority that
was not rock you know I was no way like
I couldn't do it I'm not built that way
I think most people aren't built that
way that's that's my questions about
Robert and Trevor that you know it's
just so difficult I would not try and
start a start-up just with just myself
as the founder hmm I don't think I could
do it yeah it's lonely enough anyway
think you can but I couldn't so um you
need a good solid founding team who know
one another well and who can work
together just like stuff pause they're
like knowing one another well why does
that even matter because what happens in
a startup
will shake your relationship if there's
any sort of flakiness or uncertainty or
disloyalty or whatever like lingering in
there it will emerge under the stresses
of a start-up yeah it's like a marriage
only harder you spend more time with
that purpose other differences there's
there's potentially yeah okay so you get
a good founding team you get someone who
you can stand stress with so there's two
categories of stuff there's two
categories of answers we could give here
like there's the answer you give to
investors about how to pick startups and
there's the and then there's like only a
subset of that is useful to founders
right so like if like if you you know
you could tell investors you want to
pick smart people right but founders are
as smart as they are if they party what
can we tell them get smarter right um
and actually it turns out it's not that
important to be smart um it's much much
more important to be determined if um if
you imagine if you imagine this
hypothetical person who's like a hundred
hundred out of 100 for smart and a
hundred out of 100 for determination
right and then you start taking away
determination you know it doesn't take
very long before you have this sort of
ineffectual but brilliant person um
whereas if you take someone who's like
super super determined and you start
taking away smartness bit by bit I mean
eventually you get to some guy who owns
a lot of taxi medallions but he's still
rich right or like a trash hauling
business or something like that but like
you can take away a lot of smart yeah
you take a lot of smart and and add and
take away a bunch of ethics at the same
time and then you get that guy right he
could be President
yeah I've been thinking about what like
zoos thought that would Trump would
actually teach an important lesson yeah
for startups it's all about
determination I was think about these
axes we we think about and those are two
like of the intelligence axis and the
determination axis and and obviously if
you were really intelligent really
determined that's awesome there's by the
way only one person has to be super
determined right right so like you know
you can have one person who really wants
to start the one the company and look in
person
you and Robin exactly who after a month
is like what we're still working but
that depends on this tight bond where
you can drag that person along with you
otherwise they'll go away but I was
thinking there's actually another axis
which is you have to have the ability
somewhere on your team to to to project
to think of but because your idea is
gonna suck and then it'll suck less and
less and so you have to have the ability
to think what where should we like to
navigate like you have to have some sort
of creativity that allows you to to to
like make the right choices and you know
actually you might not have to be that
creative if you care enough about users
you can just follow what what MIT what
will make users happy the way the way a
scientist follows the truth and
eventually without much thinking on your
the need to grow will give you this
product idea that's actually the product
that's the result of evolution so maybe
you're either sort of Steve Jobs and can
intuit what customers need or you just
have to have the skill of actually
talking to customers and understanding
what they're saying which isn't always
obvious you know Steve Jobs his trick
was he satisfied users to accept he was
the user it's like I don't want to have
any phone jack anymore so no more phone
jacks for anybody right maybe he was
just lucky that he his his desires were
generic enough that it was closer
everybody yeah yeah yeah he was living
in the future yeah like he didn't really
like the internet except for reading the
New York Times so he never really got
that right hmm interesting
you work didn't you work you work at
Apple at one point after you got bought
did for this it was months what was it
like what was Steve like could you tell
from where you were in Apple what Steve
was like yeah I got to talk to him a few
times he um he's different tell us tell
us how are their useful lessons you can
learn from him or Zia one off I wouldn't
presume I only met with from a handful
of times and I wouldn't presume to know
too much about them yeah you had a lot
of indirect evidence and stories and
stuff like that yeah like do you ever
see founders at YC you think to yourself
oh this is like Steve Jobs yeah I don't
think we'd I don't think we'd fun to
Steve Jobs at YC well that's not good
yeah and the reason is especially when
Steve Jobs was starting off he was an
[ __ ] oh I think actually you would
find him because Steve Jobs would make
you find him maybe right maybe we try
like we try to avoid people who who seem
like they're [ __ ] and I think like
and and and like we like you know you
wrote a whole essay on on being nice
yeah the Ronco principle right there's a
couple couples yeah be nice yeah and
called be good be good right and and I
don't think he would have passed the
test especially when he was younger
which is I worry about that because it's
true that it's usually good
to be nice and friendly and benevolent
he wasn't
maybe if YC had caught him early we
could have helped maybe maybe that would
be buddy maybe that's part of what made
him successful in the beginning I don't
know I don't know it worked for Donald
Trump Donald or did it that's a
different kind of that example right
yeah we should know what like in
business determination matters more but
like business is not identical with
startups I want to leave these these
guys some time to ask questions but I
want like what are they gonna get wrong
what what mistakes will these people
make that maybe maybe hearing them might
help it probably won't because you won't
listen but what you will get wrong is
that you will not pay enough attention
to users you will have you will make up
some idea in your own head that you will
call your vision and then you will spend
a lot of time thinking about your vision
in a cafe by yourself and right build
some elaborate thing without going and
talking to users because that's doing
sales which is a pain in the ass and
they might say no and and you'd be way
better off finding someone anyone who
has a problem that they will pay you to
fix and fixing it and then seeing if you
can find more people like that best case
is if you yourself have the problem
right but like you will not ship fast
enough because you don't want to face
the you you're embarrassed to ship
something unfinished and you don't want
to face the the the likely feedback it's
humbling and humiliating when they tell
you how shitty what you built actually
is right but that's the only way you get
it better yeah so you will shrink from
contact with the real world or contact
with your your users that's the mistake
you will make yeah there's a Paul Graham
ISM in there which is all around
launching its launching before you're
ready that some
tell people the story of its Reid
Hoffman actually who harped on that one
early not me he there's I think he said
if you're not embarrassed what with what
you launched rather than you launch too
late I remember when I was I was joining
Y Combinator and at the same time this
is not necessarily good idea of
launching imagine k12 this this EdTech
version of YC and and I came in to talk
to Paul and he's like so how's it going
with imagine k12 because he helped out a
lot and I said well it was probably
called something else well no no no
still it was by then you'd already he
actually gave us the name of Magic eight
twelve and and so it was called a magic
a twelve but it's like when you get a
launch and I was like well we're going
on our PR plan and we're finishing the
software so this was like you know we're
we're gonna have a summer batch and this
was probably in February or something
and and I said so we have like you know
probably in like six weeks he said one
he just launched when he just launched
now and I was like damn he just did it
to me and we did we launched we launched
like within a week we launched and so
that is a mistake you'll make you'll
wait too long you'll you'll you'll be
embarrassed you'll
we launched YC probably in less than a
week of having the idea of course
launching it was merely saying was
merely posting a website and and we
didn't have we didn't have any software
in the beginning people we just had this
ascii form that people would fill out
and reply to us by email the first
couple batches the applications were by
email we would print them out and pass
them around amongst the partners and
like we would all right grades on the
top like we were grading papers and then
we would sort this heap of papers and
that was the application press talking
about doing things that don't scale try
to do that with thousands of
applications now it would be harder so
we have lots of software that does that
because eventually you scale you know
eventually you you build software when
you learn what software you ought to be
building
it'd be fun to spend a lot of time more
time talking about how why she got got
started but but I think rather than that
let's some how do you have left we can
probably go to around 12 and and or all
videos that get too long or like no one
wants to watch anyway so so we've
already been going for about 40 minutes
or so so let's open it up to any
questions you guys might have yeah are
you saying that if you get if you
recruit your co-founder your friends as
co-founders you might lose them as
friends I don't think that's a big
danger I don't think you have so the
question was should I have my friends be
Cole founders and then maybe risk losing
them as friends or should I just take
someone off the street where I they're
not I don't have the risk of losing them
as friends but I they might break my
company is that was that your question
do I get that right I already answered
it dude come on I just wanted to make
sure they heard the question too just
because I repeated the question how do
you deal with different commitment
levels of co-founders and if you do have
to fire a co-founder what should you do
okay so the way you deal with different
commitment levels is you ask yourself
would I rather have 30% of this person
or a hundred percent of some other
person and in my case I would rather
have like 10% of Robert Morris's brain
than a hundred percent of almost anybody
else's so is an easy decision
how do you could fire co-founders in Y
Combinator the answer is you
you ask carolyn levy y combinator as
there's so much experience with dealing
with crap like firing co-founders and
like you just go and talk to them and
they say here you do this and this and
this right
and it's probably online too so you
could google it really is it YC
published how to follow we've we have
published we've actually if you look at
some of the talks Carolyn has given and
Christie I'm pretty sure they've covered
that particular issue one way you deal
with it by the way is making sure that
someone has a little bit more stock
perhaps like it's usually better to have
somewhat equal shares not not but not
completely equal and if one person has
51% the other person has 49% then they
can you know deadlocked yes so when you
talk about launch is launching to like
private bailout a couple of people good
enough what do you have you just launch
so what does launch really mean it means
you have actually okay so the question
is is launching in a private beta to a
few people good enough for you to have
to launch the general public I will take
launching in just a private beta to a
couple people because that's closer to
the that's closer to full launch than
like just sitting thinking of your idea
in a cafe next yes
wouldn't we come out of the currently
raising in the project maybe a little
bit rate so basically you asking about I
SEOs yeah what do you think about I CL
is Paul I have I haven't I know nothing
about this world um I've heard there's a
huge amount of crypto money floating
around um so like if there's money
floating around it's often a good idea
for startups to try and get it beyond
that I don't know but but I will say
like one of the things we've seen a lot
at Y Combinator is it's not always right
to raise too much money and even if you
don't it like the IPO thing by
definition of - it's always wrong yeah
the the ways a lot of money and the
thing about there's a couple reasons for
that one you dilute more than you
necessarily need to but the other reason
is that money just sitting there has
sort of a gravitational it makes you
suspend it and it makes you do stupid
things so it's like these companies that
have raised a billion dollars on icos
and I don't know if they'll ever have a
real company where you get like you get
a bunch of LPS and raise a billion
dollars and then you just hire so many
more people than you actually need
right I know that's the difference when
I see oh I get it but just having a
billion dollars when you only barely
have an idea is not necessarily you know
magic leap raise 2.3 billion dollars and
they seem to have almost nothing by the
way that is the trick for getting your
question answered I learned that a long
time ago you raise your hand as your fin
as people are finishing the preceding
question and and I see that guy's hand
over there he knows the trick go ahead
what is it
my best tips for a great user interview
um well you want to figure out but not
just what they think is wrong but what's
actually wrong like what's missing in
their life right so just start talking
to them like say what would you like to
do what would you like to be able to do
that you can't and they might just you
know they might they'll they'll tend to
give you an answer that's like a subset
right um like you know if you were
asking someone about email they'd like
to say I like you know I it's really
important to me to be able to mark
emails as unread right and like what
does it mean unread that whole unread
thing is a sign that the whole inbox is
being misused it's what's really going
on is it's a to-do list you know and
that's why you have to mark items as
unread so they stay on your to-do list
um and so you could so you start asking
them with what's wrong and then you try
and figure out what they really mean
what they're really getting at which
they themselves might not know you know
and then you start asking them so what
if you could do such-and-such what if
you could do such-and-such right so
start by asking them questions about
their life and then get hypothetical on
them okay we should ask someone on this
side you've taken over so you just keep
calling them you're doing great
but you you pick you'll go all right
right there in the way corner how do you
justify the financial risk of launching
a shitty product okay
so the risk of launching early is not as
great as the risk of launching late it's
not like there's only risk on one side
right there's a risk of launching late
too so you got to have a rule of thumb
about when to launch and my rule of
thumb the way I like I have this phrase
for it that didn't become as sticky as
Minimum Viable Product because it
describes what the Minimum Viable
Product has
but it's a quantum of utility right um
launch as soon as you have a quantum of
utility which means as soon as you're
there's one person in the world who is
glad that you launched because now they
can do something that they couldn't do
when there's when you if you don't if
you have something that if you launched
it no one would be happy then you're not
ready to launch right as soon as there's
at least somebody out there who would
say oh here's this thing I can use
because I can do X and before that I
couldn't do it then you should launch as
soon as you have a quantum of utility it
sounds like there's some wolves utility
function like if it makes too many
people happy and like one person happy
in like a hundred really unhappy maybe
it's not ready but if you you know Pablo
Kaito he says if you have ten people who
really love your product that's a good
place to be yeah all you need is if you
that's why if there's ten people who are
super excited
totally totally launch unlike and nobody
else cares that is perfectly fine that's
great okay well the danger of building
okay so the question is how do you
decide between building what people need
and building what people want right well
the problem is what you really want to
be doing is build something people will
choose to use or buy more becoming your
user or something like that and so
here's a counter example to the whole
need versus one thing what people need
is healthy food what people buy is
unhealthy food so if you're a business
which one do you want to do okay I mean
yeah ideally you want to make healthy
food that also tastes good right but
really um you can't you can't push this
too far
you can't push this too far I mean I
myself would not start some company
making junk food or something like that
but if you are making food
don't like or something where need and
want are very different be real careful
about picking need you know or you'll go
out and you know your goal will be to
cleanse the world of sin or something
like that it's it's easy to delude
yourself as a founder to think you're
like you yeah the other danger is what
they need is what you think they what
you what you're is implicitly talking
about is what you think they need
cleanse the world of your definition of
sin right yes yeah normal as a founder
to be to see multiple different
solutions yeah sure absolutely you just
have to pick one pick the one that you
think could get could get usage quickest
what's the founder DNA founder DNA
bothers you mean what makes a what makes
someone a founder
yes it choose to be one what makes
someone a good founder a combination of
positive and negative things I think
positive things are things like
determination and you know willingness
to try new things but then there may
also be negative things like if if you
are I think if you have worked for a
large company for twenty years you might
not be a founder unless you were forced
to for visa reasons because if you were
the kind of person that would that would
make a good founder you wouldn't be able
to stand working for a large company for
twenty years right and so actually we've
noticed certain companies where the the
alumni of these companies tend to make
bad founders and it's because no one who
would make a good founder could have
stood working
for these companies for very long okay
maybe we should pick one on this side
okay what do you what are you price
during lunch well you can probably guess
if you know your business you know
roughly what you should charge so you
should probably just go with whatever
you'd guess if you want to be more
scientific about it you could try
talking to it talking to some potential
users most of the time you have some
sort of tame users who are actual users
but are also friends of yours or
something like that or family and you
can ask them
tell me honestly like what would you
actually pay for this right um you can
always change your prices later though
if you want to lower your prices no
one's gonna complain and if you want a
grant if you want to raise your prices
you just grandfather your existing users
which if you have exponential growth
will always be a tiny subset of your
total users and then no one will
complain about that either so don't
sweat about it too much
one way I think about that is it just
seems like in the beginning what you
need more than anything is customers and
you want them to pay so you will need to
pick a price that gets you customers so
you'll learns because you learned so
much from those customers and you're
right
don't lose don't leave you customer
price yeah cuz in the beginning you just
want growth because the customers teach
you the first customers don't just give
you money they teach you all right two
more questions you choose you you pick
to you okay right up front here angel
investing so my name is Karen and I'm
with chat goose which is a chat manager
so three tips for dealing with and
finding angel investors if you don't
have you know the original goals etc
well we never talked about fundraising
at all well maybe I'll have to do this
whole thing again that's good fun
fundraising as it is it as a as a Nakia
is the thing to occupy your thoughts as
a founder is overrated it's better not
to be spending all your time thinking
about fundraising we come to it much
later in the class
we don't need to all right so the
question was how to find angel investors
well that's the part that's the thing
I'm particularly ill-suited to answering
that question because Y Combinator is
like this machine for funneling angel
investors into all the startups that it
accepts so like how do you find angel
investors if you don't it's like asking
a pilot how to you know walk along and
track on the ground I know the least
about that um here's the thing angel
investors are looking for you
so get out there go to I don't know well
there's there's lots of startup events
the angels are ancient like they're not
necessarily good angels but angels are
out there looking and the look the best
way to actually meet angels is to get
one to invest in you and then to
introduce you to people actually I know
the answer to this I know the answer
find find people who work at startups
and ask them to introduce you to their
investors that's the way to do it that's
good that's a good answer
okay last question Paul you get to you
get to choose maybe from this right
there is why is he thinking of going
after high school students to fund well
I don't know because I don't think on
behalf of YC anymore but you better not
be because that would be an evil thing
to do there at wise high school students
could there are plenty of high school
students who could start successful
startups but they shouldn't just because
you could start a successful startup
doesn't mean you should because if you
start a successful startup like that
means like the you know the Footloose
and francy fancy-free days of your life
are over hey that like you're going for
that company but we have funded kids in
high school but only because they're
already going like like it's that we're
not encouraging that I agree you think
to go to high school encourage kids to
like do this incredibly hard thing
instead of how
fun and like like being kids that's
that's awful I actually think that it's
MoMA Chur optimization to write what you
should be doing when you're in high
school and even college is you should be
figuring out what the options are
we're not picking one option and running
with it right and you know it just turns
out that usually people who are in
school and then stop to start companies
it's like you know there are dropouts
from Harvard we know the classic
examples but if you have like if you
drop out and just go do it and it's
you're on a path that's one thing but
most people like they're dabbling and
they have a fallback and that's not a
good way to be a startup founder you
have to be a hundred percent committed
and so we'll fund people in college
maybe even high school if they're
already clearly a 100% committed
otherwise no whatever Trent I think that
trend you're talking about is that is
that you graduate from high school and
why bother getting a college degree
because you're already a fantastic
hacker so I'm going to hire you and and
if that person wants to enter the
professional workforce well that that's
great I don't know I was I don't think I
would it would have been good for me it
wouldn't have been good for me either
but you know like go off and start just
some startup I just think between 18 and
22 you grow a lot as a human being who's
human and humane and it's not clear what
what society will turn into if we if all
those folks enter the workforce it's
it's good to like mess around and do a
whole bunch of different things in your
early 20s if you could have work yeah
whether it's whether this messing around
doing a whole bunch of things takes the
form of college or something else just
like don't be careful because like
starting a startup is like catching a
dragon by the tail if it works it like
be careful at what point in your life
you do that Paul thank you very much for
coming in thank you deaf
you
you